اكثر من 22 عاما مرت على هذه اللحظات
العصيبه احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
وتلتها حروب عده اودت بحياه ملايين
المدنيين والعسكريين تقرير جديد لجامعه
براون الامريكيه ونشرته واشنطن بوست قال
ان توابع هجمات سبتمبر من حربي العراق
وافغانستان اضافه لموجات الهجمات
الارهابيه اسهمت في زياده اعداد الوفيات
ومنذ عام 2010 يقوم فريق مكون من 50 باحثا
وخبيرا قانونيا اضافه الى عاملين في مجال
حقوق الانسان بمتابعه وتحليل الارقام
جامعه براون قالت ان الوفيات بفعل
النزاعات بافغانستان وباكستان والعراق
وسوريا وليبيا والصومال وعده دول اخرى
وصلت الى رقم يقارب اربعه ملايين الف شخص
وهو رقم في تزايد مستمر
وبحسب اخر تقدير لهم فان 906 الاف شخص من
بينهم
387 الف مدني ماتوا بشكل مباشر في مرحله
ما بعد هجمات سبتمبر من بين حالات الوفيات
سجل التقرير ثلاثه ملايين الف وفاء غير
مباشره نجمت عن التدهور الاقتصادي والبيئي
والنفسي والظروف الصحيه
التقرير اعتمد على الارقام فقط دون تحديد
مسؤوليه الوفيات وان كانت مقصوده خاصه مع
وجود الكثير من الاطراف المتحاربه سواء
كانت دولا ام مجموعات مسلحه حسن جوليد
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه وال
وثائق للضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات